みなさんこんにちは。はじめしゃちょーです。
みなっ
うるせー‼️
ちょっとみなさんに僕の悩み事を話そうと思います。
あの、僕動画ですごいペラペラ喋っているように見えるじゃないですか。
多分、今も動画だとすごい速度でペラペラっと喋ってるんだと思うんですけども、
あの僕、
ほんっとうに喋れなくて
自分でもちょっと今動画見返してたんですよ。
ちょっと僕の喋りが全くできないってことを皆様にも教えようと思って、
今日ちょっと自分の動画を見返してて、
なんて言うんだろうね、かっ、まっ、噛んでもいるんですよ
噛むんですけども、なんか気にくわなかったらもう一回同じことを言っちゃう
うまく説明できねぇなぁ･･･
最近もうね、ところ構わず！　日本語をぉ、適当に喋っちゃう
それもまた分かんないんですけど･･･
ま、とりあえず見てもらったら分かると思うんですけども、僕、
同じことを何回も繰り返して喋る癖が付いてしまっています。
一回ちょっと見てみてください。ＶＴＲ、どうぞ
私は今回ここに
私は今回ここにぃ
私は今回コンビニに売って
(暗いピアノの音)
今のですよ！
まぁ、これはまだ辛うじて分かりますよ
なんかこう、嫌だったんでしょうね。
自分の、この、言葉の感じが嫌でぇ
「私はいまここに」っていうことを３回言って
３回目で気に入って言ったっていう、例です
まぁ、３回も可笑しいですけど、まぁまぁ、まぁよしとしましょう。次！
普通エアホッケーってなん･･･
普通エアホッケーってどんなのか･･･
普通エアホッケーってこの･･･
普通エアホッケーってこの床から空気が出て
(悲しいピアノの音)
１回増えたね♪
普通エアホッケー、普通エアホッケーって･･･ふつ、あっ
今ももう２回言ったもん
のうどうもうなんかもう可笑しくなってんだよなんかねぇ、
間違えてもなんとかなんだろって思ってるんだろうね、編集で。
YouTuberの病気みたいになってますね。
「普通エアホッケー」っていう簡単な言葉を４回も連続で言ってるんですよ？
あれです。
あれです
えー･･･
こちらあれです
(はじめの引き笑い)
こちらあれです。線香花火でござい･･･
(悲しいピアノの音＆始めの笑い声)
「あれです」って５回も言うんだよ！？
誰もいないところで！
もー、なんか自分で見ててもかなりヤバいと思ってます
次、です。どうぞ！
はいこれ何かと言いますと、ブライトクロック･･･というものでございます
あ、これなにかと言いますとブライトクロックというものです。　現在のはじめ「なんで言いなおした？」
あーなんか考えてる。気にくわなかったんでしょうね。
えー、これ何かと言いますと･･･
これ何かと言いますと、要するにですね
これ何かと言いますとまぁ･･･
まぁ、これ何かといいますと･･･れ
これ何かと言いますと、最近ちょっと話題になっ･･･
これ何かといいますと
(悲しいピアノの音)
俺のターン･･･
あー、俺のターン、
あ、おぅ･･･俺の･･･俺のターン、みたいな
もうなんか、間違えてもいいと思ってるから日常的にも、言葉が上手く出てこないんですよね･･･
次！
チーズ･･･
チー･･･
チ･･･
チーズ味のぺヤング･･･チーズケーキ･･･
今回、今回この万能･･･
(悲しいピアノの音)
あきらめるんかい
はい！というわけでいかがだったでしょうか。
あの、特にどうするっていう訳でもないんですけど
純粋に･･･困っております。
動画の言い直しが多すぎるから
もうところかまわず噛むし、
もう、失敗してもいいことをバンバン言っちゃうから
失敗を恐れない精神になってるんですよ。
あぁ、なんかそう言ったら良い事っぽいな。
いや 良くないですよ、実際
リアルな世界だと本当に役に立たない
リアルな世界だと本当にもう
もう２回言ったもん 今ぁ！
なんか変なとこで完璧主義者なんでしょうね
絶対これがいいっていう感じで言うまでたぶん
録り直さないと気が済まないようになってるんで
たぶん動画の裏側だとこんなふうに
メチャクチャなことになってるんです、実は
っていう悩み事
まぁ編集で何とかするから
皆さんには問題ないんですけど
これを繰り返してるせいで
日常でも結構言葉のミスが多くなってるんで
ますます僕のコミュ障が
加速するぜ！
さぁ みんな月曜日　頑張っていきましょう
バイバイ